it's estimated that 75 of english words
come from other languages it's a very
grabby language if it sees something it
likes it takes it that makes it kind of
the
england of languages that's one reason
english has amassed one of the biggest
vocabularies on earth
no one knows exactly how many but it's
surely in the hundreds of thousands
and yet there are still gaps in the
lexicon
there are just too many things and ideas
and experiences for one dictionary to
hold but hey we can try we add almost a
thousand words a year to the english
language so if we're going to continue
yoinking words from other languages i
have a few suggestions these are words
that describe concepts that everyone can
relate to but we don't get to say in
english that's not to say that they're
entirely untranslatable because we can
do our best approximation of them but
there's that intuition that a non-native
speaker wouldn't have that je ne sais
quoi if you will that phrase is barred
from the french for i don't know what
but now refers to that little something
something that's indefinable or
uh
if you think my french is bad just wait
till you hear my innuptitude i'm dr
erica brazovsky and let's take a look at
some other words because after all this
is other
[Music]
words other words
some concepts are so universal it's a
surprise we don't have words for them
already
here's a good example
what do you call it when you think of
the perfect witty comeback or snappy
retort but hours after the fact
essentially the opposite of a repost
english may leave you hanging but
yiddish and german and french all have a
term for that blown mic drop opportunity
trap better trupp nvitz and the spree de
scalier which all roughly translate to
staircase wit
likely because you think of these
comebacks when you're leaving walking
down the staircase away from what could
have been such a satisfying linguistic
beatdown
and maybe you're so flustered that on
your way home you ask someone for
directions and say yep got it thanks and
get one block away and then immediately
forget what they said
hawaiian's got a word for that akihi
they also have a term pawn up o for
scratching your head in order to
remember something you've forgotten
which might help with remembering those
directions have you ever recklessly
taken a bite of food only to realize
it's the temperature of molten lava you
don't want to spit it back onto your
plate in front of your date and you're
not about to flambe your esophagus so
your only choice is to keep it moving
around in your mouth while sucking in
air
where english fails us bully a language
spoken in ghana saves the day and maybe
our taste buds as well palenti literally
means to move hot food in your mouth and
as an impatient eater it happens to me
more often than i care to admit we all
try to listen to our body when it's
saying it's full but you know sometimes
there's something left on your plate and
you want to eat it because it's
delicious but you don't want to eat the
whole thing because you're not actually
hungry anymore so you have a little
spoonful here and maybe a nibble there
and and all of a sudden it's gone and by
accident you've become part of the clean
plate club
not just me right
well i know it's not because georgians
only need one word shimomachama to
express what took me uh
79 words to describe
speaking of mindless eating korean has a
word for that feeling of wanting to eat
not because you're particularly hungry
but because your mouth is bored
a more wistful way of expressing a
similar sentiment the japanese version
kuchi sabichi means to eat because your
mouth is lonely
and then when you've satisfied your
mouth and you're feeling a little sleepy
ah there's an italian word for that
abioko like food relationships are
universally important to humans so there
are many words to describe social
interactions with special cultural
nuance and what better way to start than
around the dinner table
in spanish culture you don't just chow
down and get out sobremesa refers to the
time you spend lingering around the
table enjoying your time talking
drinking coffee or a digestive for hours
with no rush to get onto the next thing
even at a busy restaurant the dutch have
a word for it too and tufflin many of us
have heard of the danish word made
famous by a certain book
hygge
which highlights the custom of
cultivating an environment of warmth
coziness and togetherness which i
imagine is important to prioritize when
it's dark and cold for half of the year
and speaking of togetherness the inuit
people use pilirikat guineak to describe
community spirit and working together
for the common good
in warmer places you might appreciate
the time after the sun has gone down a
little bit more so in arabic samar means
staying up late after the sun has set
and enjoying time with friends
it also refers to evening conversations
that might include arabic music and
poetry i love how much meaning can be
packed into one word
not that they're the authority on the
matter but the guinness book of world
records has weighed in on what word does
it best the yagan people whose last
remaining speaker died in 2022 used
mommy lapina tapai to describe that
meaningful look shared between two
people who both want to start something
but are unwilling or hesitant to do so
hoping that the other person will
initiate
boy that would save rom-com writers a
lot of time and as a non-native speaker
of all the languages mentioned so far
just know that these explanations are
simply scratching the surface so here's
a word from my own idiolect that i found
impossible to translate exactly mafan
a mandarin dictionary will say it means
troublesome or annoying both as an
adjective and a verb but it's also so
much more i asked my mom how she defined
it in english and she said my fun is
inconvenient but i had to do it
like making this film for my dear
daughter erica
i also asked my taiwanese american
community and got a wide range of
answers
and i've used mafan in all of those
contexts language is complicated but
that's half the fun whether you're
looking for a word to describe a joke
that's so unfunny that it's hilarious or
the feeling that overcomes you when you
see something
so
cute that you can't help but squeeze it
there are countless beautiful moments
that exist outside of the limitations of
one language there's a word in hebrew
for the pure joy and genuine happiness
you feel about someone else's
accomplishments with no ulterior motives
and you know the way sunlight filters
through a canopy of trees shining its
dappled light on the ground
there's a japanese word for it by
learning about these so-called
untranslatable words you come to
understand that though our dictionaries
may be different the human experience is
remarkably similar across the globe
mommy lapena mommy la pena toppey
i'm so proud of my mispronunciations
guys